so listen this is been such a whirlwind
for you what does it like to be the sole
collaborator and now the hottest
producer in the entire world seemingly
overnight I know you guys have been
working at it for a long time well to be
Billy so collaborator is you know a
really wonderful feeling but it's it's a
really organic sort of situation we just
spent our whole childhood hanging out
together and then as we got a little
older we just started working on music
and creating stuff together and so you
know very little has changed in that
sense we're just still doing what we
used to not be very good at and we've
just spent more time doing it how were
those first songs well by the time we
were working together I mean I was just
so impressed by her voice and by her
kind of approach to - singing so like
the very first thing we made together
like I have a real fondness for I
cherished that stuff but that wasn't
like that long ago right the first songs
I ever wrote when I was like 12 you know
hopefully no one will ever get to hear
it's the goal is to keep them quiet
so you produce the record somewhat in
your bedroom yeah almost all of it was
done in in my bedroom that is insanity
and you guys still live with your
parents yeah at the time that the whole
making of the album we we just lived in
our parents house and made the whole
record in that bedroom and the internet
tells me that your parents gave up a
broom so that you could have a studio
bedroom and they slept in the living
room is there any truth to this story
because that is a Hollywood movie
waiting to happen even crazier I think
then that which is that we only have two
bedrooms so they didn't even give up a
room to give us a studio they just gave
up a room to give a billy a bedroom like
Billy and I I had like a tiny bedroom
because I was born first and then when
Billy was born she slept in their bed
for a couple years because we have like
a hippie family yeah and then as she got
a little older and needed space they
just slept on a futon in the living room
so we we were across the hall from each
other and then made all of the record in
my room yeah that is crazy dude could
you have even imagined like tonight
you're playing the Grammy Museum people
are talking about you guys for album of
the year song of the year best new
artist I mean that is insane could you
have even dreamed a dream this big no no
I mean the Grammy Museum
me like I I came here growing up a lot
because it was like doubt you know we
grew up in Highland Park this is like a
18-minute drive so we would we'd come
see whoever we could get tickets to see
and ticket sell out really fast that the
gray museum because it's like a hundred
seat theater it's very small so we we
became like members of the museum which
is like an annual thing and then we
would just try to go to see everybody we
saw Colbie Caillat and Macklemore and
Ryan Lewis and childish gambino and so
to me it was like always like heroes of
mine that I was seeing here so no I mean
it was always you know just unbelievable
crazy oh that's crazy
yeah and so in addition to working with
Billie you actually have your own EP as
well and your own music what's the
differences and what are the
sound-alikes well the the things that
are different I guess is that what I'm
working with her I'm just trying to
focus on like telling her story and just
helping her articulate whatever she
wants to say which doesn't necessarily
mean like all her life story but like
whatever stories she wants to tell
I think songs like bad guy and bellyache
are very kind of like sort of fantasy
like she's telling this like sort of
like fairy tale and I think I'm trying
to do the same thing for myself it's
just like different perspectives you
know and then I think the the tied
together is probably just like a lot of
a lot of vocal harmony back so I can
imagine now that the I'd like to say
like the Billie Eilish sound is out and
it cut through what was like one sound
that we've heard on the radio and was
like so fresh to stuff yeah that you're
getting a gazillion requests will Finn
come do my record now my name is Beyonce
or whatever how often are you getting
hit up for that kind of thing not just
put soul producer I feel really lucky to
be getting asked to work on stuff a lot
and I'm I'm always excited to I think
that the only thing I ever shy away from
is anyone that's trying to sound like
Billie yeah cuz I'm always like well no
one can sound like Billie she's so
unique and she's so her own artist so
I'm the only stuff I'm really excited
about is stuff that is in its own way
super unique do you want to tell our
super small world like base looking not
millions of people at all like who those
collaborations might be
Entertainment Tonight or you want to
just keep that to yourself yeah I'll
just say a couple that have already
happened that haven't come out yet those
I love that I've already happened I got
to write a song with John Legend really
recently which was a dream come true for
me and that was like I was like being in
a classroom like he is so brilliant that
I just was like listening the whole day
and so just really it's crazy scary
talented and then I think I have a song
on kamila Kibeho s' new record and she's
a close friend of mine so that was just
really exciting it's amazing
congratulate so what happens in your DMS
I want there are more people asking you
out are they asking you to collaborate
on music or are they asking for secrets
about Billy or tickets to Billy concert
probably in the in the in the the broad
scale of the M there's a lot of very
sweet followers of both Billy and I who
want me to pass messages of love to
Billy which is great I'll never stop
that and then there's there's a fair
amount of like bro come listen to this
track yeah this is a mistic 50/50 I'm
sure yeah last thing Julia Roberts is a
fan what is it like for Julia Roberts to
be like you're amazing that's the way
you're done yeah you get to quit after
that I think yeah she's the sweetest and
I'm in the middle of I'm like a year
late because we've just had a crazier
but I'm in the middle of homecoming
right now I'm on like episode six or
something of homecoming and that shows
in st. she's so good in it and the show
is just like every at home and episode
ends I'm so bummed I just like have to
watch the next episode
[Applause]
[Music]